The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK let's get started.
Let's get started, please.
All right, last time we talked
about information and entropy.
The picture we had
was of some kind
of a source emitting symbols.
Symbols-- let's say n of them.
So it chooses from these symbols
with probabilities P1 up to Pn.
And then we talked about the
expected information here,
or the entropy, so the
expected information
you get when you see the symbol
that's emitted by the source.
And that was the average
value of the information.
So it was-- let's see,
you take 1 over log of 1
over P i for each of
the possible symbols.
And then you've
got to weight it by
the corresponding probability
to get an expectation.
And this was the
entropy of the source.
Or if you want to make
explicit the source,
you could say H
of S for source--
capital S. All right?
And then we were actually
thinking of this operating
repeatedly.
So in the model we had last
time, the source at each time
chooses from one of these
symbols with this probability.
And it does it independently
of choices at other times.
So what the source
actually generates
is what's referred to as
an iid sequence of symbols,
independent,
identically distributed.
You'll see this a lot--
Or iid sequence of symbols.
So the independent part
of this refers to the fact
that it makes the
choice independently
at each time instant.
The identically
distributed means
that at each time
instant, it goes back
to these same probabilities.
It's the same distribution
that it uses each time.
So that's what iid means--
so sort of a stationary
probabilistic source
with no dependence from one
time instant to the next.
Average information was
measured in bits per symbol.
And what we wanted to do
was take those symbols
and compress them
to binary digits.
OK, so we were going to--
you can compress
them to other things.
We were going to think of
compressing them to binary
digits because we're thinking
of a channel that can take 0s 1s
or a signal that's in
two possible states.
So what we wanted to do was
take each symbol or sequence
of symbols and code it in
the form of binary digits.
Right?
Now, each binary
digit can, at most,
carry one bit of information.
If the binary digit is equally
likely to be a 0 or a 1,
then it carries one
bit of information.
So that tells you really
that if you're going
to code this, the code length--
let's see-- compress to binary
digits, let's say, or encode.
And what we need is the
expected code length.
L should be greater
than or equal to H. So
you need to transmit at
least this many binary digits
on average to convey
the information that's
coming out of the source--
per symbol or per timestamp.
All right, so that
was the basic setup.
I've given you one
of these bounds here.
When we talked about
codes, by the way,
we decided that if we're
talking about binary codes,
we want to limit ourselves to
what are called instantaneously
decodable or prefix-free codes.
And these are codes
that correspond
to the leaves of a code tree.
So we had examples of this type.
You want your symbols
to be associated
with the leaves of--
the end of the tree, not
intermediate points.
The reason being
that, as you work
your way down to the tree--
by the way, I'm assuming
that this picture makes sense
to you in some fashion
from recitation.
But as you work your
way down to the symbol,
you don't encounter any
other symbols on the way.
So as soon as you
hit the leaf, you
know what symbol you've got.
So we're limiting
ourselves to codes
of that type because
some of the statements
I make are not true if you
don't have codes of this type.
So I won't comment
on that again.
All right, so we've got
that, the first inequality
that I've put up there.
And it turns out
that Shannon showed
how to actually construct
codes that will give you
a band on the other side.
Let me actually write it
the way it is on the slide.
So Shannon showed how to get
codes that satisfy this-- so
can get code satisfying this.
So Shannon showed
how to get within one
of the lower bound in terms
of the expected length
of the code.
So that was pretty good.
But after coming up
with this paper in '48
and working on this for a while,
neither he nor other luminaries
in the field had found how
to get the best such code,
and that's what
Huffman ended up doing.
So we've talked
about that already.
OK, so Huffman showed
how to get a code
of minimum expected
length per symbol
with a very simple construction.
Now, you can actually
extend Huffman--
and maybe you talked about
this in recitation as well.
So you can code
per symbol, or you
can decide you're going
to create super-symbols.
Take the same source, but say
that the symbols that it emits
are the symbols from here
grouped two at a time.
So you're going to
take the symbol emitted
at some particular time
and then the symbol
at the following time and
call that a super-symbol.
And then take the
next pair, and that's
a super-symbol and so on.
So you're doing
the Huffman coding,
but on pairs of symbols.
So you can go through the
same kind of construction.
If you assuming an iid
source, then the probability
of a paired super-symbol
is easy to compute.
It's just a probability
of the individual ones
because they're
independently emitted.
And then the entropy
of the resulting source
here turns out to be twice
the entropy of the source
here because these are
independent emissions,
so the entropies will just add.
So you can do the Huffman
construction again.
And what you discover is
the same kind of thing
except this is now
the inequality, right?
And the reason is--
well, here L is still the
expected length per symbol.
But you're doing pairs
now, so the expected length
for the pair is 2L.
Right?
The lower bound is the
entropy of the source.
That's 2H.
The upper bound is the
entropy of that source plus 1.
So you can construct
a code of that type.
You can do it with Shannon's
construction or Huffman's.
And now see what
you've managed to do.
You've got a little titer of a
squeeze on the expected length.
So we've gone from H
plus 1 to H plus 1/2
with this construction.
If you took triples, this
would just change to 1 over 3.
If you took K-tuples,
you'd get 1 over K.
So if you encode larger
and larger blocks,
you can squeeze
the expected length
down to essentially what
the entropy band tells you.
Now, Huffman-- you've
spent time in recitation.
I just thought I would
quickly run through an example
so that you have this
fresh in your minds.
So we start off with
a set of symbols.
This is kind of weak,
but I hope you can it.
A set of symbols, A through D
in this case, with probabilities
associated with it.
The Huffman process
is to first sort
these symbols in descending
order of probability.
So that's what I
really start with.
You take the two
smallest ones and lump
them together to get a paired
symbol, rearrange, reorder.
And then you do the
same thing again.
You take the two,
combine them, reorder.
Take the two smallest ones,
And that's what you have
for your reduction phase.
And then you start
to trace back.
So when you trace back, you can
pick the upper one to be zero,
the lower one to be 1.
And then every time you get a
bifurcation, as you go back,
you'll pick the upper one to be
zero and the lower one to be 1.
And you start to build
up your code word, right?
So this one traces back.
There's no bifurcation.
This traces back.
The 0 becomes 0001.
And you go all
the way like that.
OK?
So trace back-- let's see.
Oh, was there a--
yeah.
So the 1 here becomes
a 1 0 and a 1 1.
And then at the next step,
you're all the way back
with the Huffman code.
Right?
So that's the Huffman code
for that set of symbols.
It's a Huffman code.
I shouldn't say the Huffman
code because, if you notice,
at various stages
we had probabilities
that were identical, like over
here and over here and over
here.
And we could have chosen
how to order these things
and then how to do the
subsequent grouping.
And all of those will
give you Huffman codes
with the same minimum
expected length.
All right.
All right, I want to give
you another way of thinking
about entropy and why
it enters into coding.
And here's the basic idea.
All right, so we're still
thinking about the source
emitting independent symbols.
It's an iid source.
And we've got a very
long string of emissions.
So we've got a very long
string of symbols emitted,
maybe S1 of the first time,
S17 here, S2 here, and so on.
And the question is, in a
very long string of symbols,
how many times do you
expect to see symbol S1?
How many times you expect to
see a symbol S2 and so on?
Well, if you
actually work it out,
it turns out that
the expected number
of times, number of times we
see SI in the [INAUDIBLE] symbol
is K times the
probability of seeing SI.
So it's what you'd expect.
All right?
So the expected number
of times is that.
Well, but that doesn't tell
you what the number of times
is that you'll see in
any given experiment.
We know that you need to think
about standard deviations
as well.
So what this is saying is,
for instance, for symbol SI,
that we expect to get
that many of symbol SI.
But actually, there's a
distribution around it.
So you'll get a
little histogram here.
I'm not making any attempt
to draw it very carefully,
but there's a distribution.
You run different
experiments, you're
going to get different numbers
of SI in that run of K. Right?
So there's a distribution.
And it turns out
you can actually
write an explicit formula
for the standard deviation.
This is something you'll see
if you do a probability course.
It's actually very simple.
So that's the
standard deviation.
So the standard
deviation goes as root K.
So the interesting thing is
that the standard deviation is
a fraction of--
the number of successes
get smaller and smaller
as K becomes larger and larger.
Or another way to see that
is, if I normalize this,
so I'm going to do a
number of successes
divided by K. This histogram
is going to cluster around P i.
And the standard deviation
now, because I've divided by K,
the standard deviation
actually now ends
up being P1 minus P square
root of K. All right?
So what this says is
if you get a run of K
emissions of the symbol
and you try and estimate
the probability, P i by taking
the ratio of times SI appears
over the total number
of runs, you'll
actually get a little
spread here centered on P i.
But the spread actually
goes down as 1 over root K.
So this is really what the law
of large numbers is telling us.
It's telling us that if
you take a very long run,
you almost certainly get
a number of successes,
well, Kp i in this case.
It's very tightly concentrated.
All right, we don't want you
to remember all these formulas.
I have them on the slides.
It's just there for fun.
There's something else
that I put on there
that you can try out for fun.
I don't want to talk through
it, but you can use exactly this
to analyze things like polling.
Why is it that you
can poll 2,500 people
and say that I've
got a margin of error
of 1% as to how the election
is going to turn out?
Well, the answer is,
actually, in exactly this.
If we have time at the
end, I'll come back to it.
But it's easy enough that
you can look at it yourself.
So let's focus on what it
is I wanted to show you.
I picked Obama 0.55, but that
was just as illustration.
[LAUGHTER]
No.
No political views to
be imputed to that.
All right, so what
we're saying is you've
got K emissions of this symbol.
And with very high
probability, you've
got Kp1 one of S1,
Kp2 of S2, and so on.
So this is really what
you're expecting to get,
provided you've tossed this
a large number of times.
What's the probability of
getting a sequence that has Kp1
of S1, Kp2 of S2, and so on?
So you've got to get
S1 and Kp1 positions.
What's the probability of that?
And you've got to get
S2 and Kp2 positions.
So how do you work out
those probabilities?
We're invoking independence
of all the emissions.
So you can multiply
probabilities.
So what you have is S1
occurring with probability.
P1 to the power
Kp1, because P1 is
the probability with
which S1 occurs,
and it's happening Kp1 times.
So you take it to that power,
and then P2 to the Kp2,
all the way up to Pn to the Kpn.
OK?
So this is the probability of
getting a sequence like this.
And what we've said is this
is the only kind of sequence
you're typically going to get.
All the rest have very low
probability of occurrence.
So it must be that when I
add up all these sequences,
I get, essentially,
probability 1.
So the question then is how
many such sequences are there.
If a single sequence
of this type
has this probability, and the
only sequences I'm going to get
are sequences of this
type effectively,
and the probabilities
have to sum to 1.
How many sequences do
I have of this type?
Do you agree that it's
1 over the probability?
The number of such sequences?
Because I've got to take the
number of sequences times
this individual probability
has to come up to be one.
Right?
The number of sequences--
let me write this down.
So that you see it
a little better.
The number of such--
let me call them
typical sequences--
times the probability
of any such sequence
has got to be approximately 1.
I say approximately because
there are a few other sequences
whose probabilities might--
I would have to take a count of.
But this is essentially it.
So the number of such sequences
is 1 over this number.
is P1 to the minus K1,
P1, P2 to the minus
Kp2 and so on.
That's the number
of such sequences.
And essentially, these
are all the sequences
that I'm going to get.
Well, if I take
the log of this--
just visualize
how the log works.
Now I've got the
log of a product,
so that going to be a sum
of the individual logs.
I've got the log of
a power of something,
so the power will come
down to multiply the log.
This comes out to be K
times H of S exactly.
OK, so the log of the
number of sequences
is K times H of S,
K times the entropy.
This is log to the base 2.
So the number of sequences
is equal to 2 to the KH.
I'm saying equal to.
I should be putting
approximately
equal to signs everywhere,
but you get the idea.
So the number of typical
sequences is 2 to the KH.
How many binary digits does it
take to count 2 the KH things?
KH, right?
So what I need is--
so I just need KHS binary digits
to count the typical sequences.
So how many binary digits
do I need per symbol?
It's just that divided
by K because I've
got a string of K symbols.
So I need a number of binary
digits equal to the entropy.
So this is a quick way
of seeing that entropy
is very relevant to minimal
coding of sequences of outputs
from a source like this.
All right, now I swept a
lot of math under the rug.
The math that makes
this rigorous exists.
We don't want to have
any part of it here.
But for those of you
who are inclined,
you can look in a book
on information theory.
There's a nice name to it.
It's called the
Asymptotic Equipartition--
Equipartition Property.
OK?
It's basically saying that,
asymptotically the probability
partitions into equal
probabilities for all
these typical sequences.
All right.
So all that is for Huffman
and its application
to symbols emitted independently
by a source over time.
But there are
limitations to this.
We've been working with Huffman
coding under the assumption
that the probabilities
are given to us.
But it's typically the case
that the probabilities are not
known for some arbitrary source
that you're trying to code for.
The probabilities might
change with time as the source
characteristics change.
So you would need to
detect that and recode,
if you're going to do Huffman.
And then the more
important point
perhaps is that sources
are generally not iid.
The sources of
interest are not really
generating independent
identically
distributed symbols.
What's perhaps
more true is that--
let's see.
Oh, here-- once you're done
compressing your source
to binary digits where
each binary digit carries
a bit of information,
then you've
got something that essentially
is not correlated over time.
You've managed to
kind of decouple it.
But at this stage, these symbols
are not really independent
in typical cases of interest.
So one important case, of
course, is just English text.
You can still code
it symbol by symbol,
but it's a very
inefficient coding.
If you wanted to do
it symbol by symbol,
let's just ignore uppercase.
You've got 26
letters plus a space.
So that's 27 symbols.
Well, you could certainly code
that with five binary digits
because that would give
you 32 things to count.
You can do better
with a code that
approaches the
entropy associated
with a source of this type.
That would be 4.755 bits.
OK, so if you ignored
dependence in English text
and just treated each
symbol is equally likely,
you'd say that
that's the entropy,
and you could attempt to code
it with something approaching
that.
But actually, not all
symbols are equally likely.
If you look at a typical
distribution of frequencies--
and we saw this
with Morse already.
The E is much more common than
T, than A, O, I, N and so on.
So there is a
distribution to this.
But you can take account of
that distribution and compute
the associated entropy, and
you get something a little bit
smaller, 4.177 instead of
the 4.7-something that we
hadn't before.
Because not all letters
are equally likely.
But this is still thinking
of it symbol by symbol,
not recognizing
dependence over time.
But English and other
languages are full of context.
Right?
If you know the preceding
part of the text,
you have a very good way
to guess the next letter.
Nothing can be said to
be certain except death
and-- well, you
can-- in this case,
you can give me the
next three letters.
Right?
Anyone?
AUDIENCE: It's taxes
PROFESSOR: Taxes, yeah.
So even though X
taken in isolation
has a very low
probability of occurrence,
if you look at the histogram
on the previous page,
you see that the
probability is 0.0017.
Letters are not
independently generated.
Now, it turns out Shannon was
actually one of the earliest
to study this in
experiments on his wife.
He had her-- he presented
her with bits of text
from one particular
book and asked
her to guess the next
letter and so on.
And he had a 1951 paper
that actually launched
a lot of this, because
he had developed now
the tools for talking about it.
His estimate was much lower
than the 4-point-something.
It was more in the vicinity
of one bit, 1 to 1.5 bits.
So there's a lot of compression
possible with English text
because there's this kind
of a dependence here.
And just to tell you
what it is that we're
trying to compute when
we compute entropy
for these long
sequences of symbols,
we're sort of saying what's
the joint entropy of a sequence
of K symbols divided by K in the
limit of K going to infinity.
So this is what you
might call H under bar.
It's not over bar
because I couldn't
see how to do an over
bar on my PowerPoint.
But it's usually an
over bar in the books.
But this is really the
object that you would
like to get your hands on.
For sequential text
that has context in it,
this is the kind of
entropy that you really
would like to be working with.
OK.
So that brings us to
an approach to coding
that's really focused--
coding or compression
that's really
focused on sequential text.
And this is the Lempel-Ziv-Welch
algorithm that's in the notes.
Turns out that Lempel
and Ziv or Ziv and Lempel
had two earlier papers.
And then Welch improved
on it in an '84 paper.
And what's in blue over
there is a bit of a mouthful.
And each word kind
of means something,
so I thought I'd
list it all there.
Maybe I've used too
many of these words--
universal lossless compression
of sequential or streaming data
by adaptive variable
length coding.
And I'll come to talk about
those terms on the next slide.
And it turns out that this is
a very widely used compression
algorithm for all
sorts of files.
Sometimes it's for a part of it.
Sometimes it's optional.
Sometimes it's
combined with Huffman,
but all of these things
that do compression
pay homage to Lempel
and Ziv at least.
They were also patented.
Actually, Unisys owned the
patent on LZW for many years.
These have all expired now.
But while the patents were held,
it made for a lot of heartburn
because there were
things being done
without knowledge of the
existence of the patents.
And then people got hit
with lawsuits and so on.
Jacob Ziv, again part of this
incredible heritage from MIT
of people working here in
the early days of information
theory.
He was a graduate student here
at the same time as Huffman
and many other people whose
names surface in all of this.
I was actually at an award
ceremony of the IEEE,
where Lempel got an award
for his compression work.
And people were given a whole
minute for a thank you speech,
a mini thank you speech.
And everyone took their minute
to mention this person and that
and talk about the
origins of the work.
It's a lot to say
in a minute but they
managed to convey a lot.
Lempel came up and
said, "thank you."
[LAUGHTER]
It seemed kind of fitting
for someone whose life
is devoted to compression.
[LAUGHTER]
I just couldn't help
but crack up there.
That was-- all right.
Now the interesting
thing about this
is that there are
theoretical guarantees
that, under
appropriate assumptions
on the source, asymptotically,
this process will
attain that bound.
Now the thing is, the word
asymptotically hides many sins.
Lots of things happen
at infinity that
are not supposed to happen.
Or lots of things happen
at infinity that never
happen when you're watching.
So the theoretical
performance perhaps
is not as important as the fact
that it works exceedingly well
in practice.
So we're going to talk
a little bit about it.
You've got a lab on it as well.
So let me just say a little bit
about what these words mean.
So this is universal
in the sense
that it doesn't
necessarily-- it doesn't
need any knowledge of
the particular statistics
of the source that
it's compressing.
It's willing to take
its hand at anything.
OK?
So it doesn't need to know
the source statistics.
It actually learns
the source statistics
in the course of
implementing the algorithm.
And it does that by
actually building up
a dictionary for
strings of symbols
that it discovers
in the source text.
So it's built around
construction of a dictionary.
What it then does is
it compresses the text,
not to things that we've
seen here in Huffman,
but to actually
dictionary entries.
So it's sort of like
Morse's original idea,
which was communicate the
address in the dictionary
rather than communicating
the word itself
or some compressed
version of the word.
So it compresses the
text to sequences
of dictionary addresses,
and those are the code words
that it sends to the receiver.
It's also a variable
length compression scheme.
But it's interesting
that it doesn't
take a fixed length of symbols
to varying lengths of code
words.
It actually takes
varying lengths
of symbols to fixed
length of code words.
So it's a little bit backwards.
But it's still a variable
length in that sense.
So the way this works is that
the sender and the receiver
start off with a core dictionary
that they both agreed on.
And for our
illustrations, we might
say that they've
agreed on the letters A
through Z, lowercase
A through Z.
So what they have is these
letters or this core dictionary
stored in some register.
Well, actually let me show
you what it might look like.
So there's the register
with, let's say,
you have an 8-bit table.
This is the dictionary
that you have at both ends.
So you can store 256
different things.
And you've both agreed on what's
going to go into those slots.
So somewhere-- I think
it's slot 97 in one
of these particular codes,
you've got the letter A.
And somewhere else
you've got B, and so on.
Or the next position
you've got B.
You can store a bunch
of standard symbols.
So we'll consider that
all the single letter
symbols are already stored
in designated positions
in this dictionary that's known
to the sender and the receiver.
So if the sender just
sends 252, the receiver
knows what 252 refers
to because they've
got that core dictionary
that they've agreed on.
Some of the text
here, by the way,
is stuff I've said already.
So I'll actually go back.
And then what happens is
that the source starts
to sequentially scan
the text that's arriving
or that it's looking at and
puts new strings that it's
found into new
locations in this table
and then communicates the
address for the receiver.
The magic of this-- and I mean
it's fiendishly clever, very
simple, but very clever, is
that the receiver can build up
its dictionary in tandem with
the transmitter building up
the dictionary.
It's just a one-step delay.
So one step later,
the receiver has
figured out what that
dictionary entry is.
So the transmitter or the source
is building up the dictionary,
looking at strings in
the input sequence,
communicating the address--
the addresses of the appropriate
strings to the receiver,
and the receiver is building
up a dictionary in parallel.
Now I think the easiest
way to do this--
there's discussion in the text.
There's also code fragments.
But I think the
easiest way for me
to try and do this is to
actually just show you
how it works on a
particular sequence.
And you may not get all
the details all at once.
I do have a little animation
that I need to tweak a bit,
and I'll--
well, it's not an animation,
but a set of slides
that'll help you
understand, actually,
this particular example.
So I'll have that
posted as well.
But for now, let's
just work through this
and see what it looks like.
And I hope I don't trip
over myself in the process.
I hope you'll be forgiving.
And I need these two
blackboards to do it.
OK.
And I need some colored chalk.
So what I'm going to have
over here is the source.
And over here is the receiver.
And the source wants to send
a message that I'll put here--
A-B-C. This is going to
look incredibly boring.
But the algorithm does different
things at different stages,
so that keeps it interesting.
And let's see 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And then we hit a special case
somewhere near the end here
that is worth sorting out.
Because otherwise
that, the fragment
of the code that you
see doesn't make sense.
Gee, can you believe that I
want to start this again here?
Sorry.
Let's start here.
I want at least six
replications of ABC.
I want you to get
comfortable also
so you can settle into this.
OK, here we go.
All right.
The receiver has no idea
that this is the sequence.
The source has, and
the receiver both
have A through Z sitting
in their dictionary
at designated locations.
So the source will
first see the letter A
and does nothing because
A is in its dictionary.
It doesn't want to
do anything yet.
Then it looks at--
it pulls in B. So now
it's looking at AB.
AB is not in its dictionary
because it's a symbol of--
it's a string of two symbols.
So now it knows it needs
to make a dictionary entry.
I'm going to indicate
dictionary entry with this.
So the source is going to
make a dictionary entry of AB.
So what this means is
somewhere in that register
in a particular position,
or in the next position
actually from the agreed on
table, it sticks in this.
And then what it transmits
to the receiver is not this,
but the code for A. OK?
So it enters the longer fragment
here as a new dictionary word
and sends the address for the
piece that the receiver sees.
So what does the receiver get?
The receiver sees A
coming in and says, OK,
that's the sequence
A. That's the symbol.
A, I'm all set.
All right?
Now what happens
is that the source
pulls in the next letter.
It's done with the A, so you can
essentially forget about that.
It pulls in the next letter.
Looks to see if it's got
B-C in its dictionary.
It doesn't have BC because it
only has single letter entries,
and it has AB.
So it's got to put in BC.
So it's going to put
in an entry for BC.
And then what it's going
to transmit is the B.
The receiver gets
the B. Oh, sorry--
the directory entry for B. And
so it knows that's the letter
B. And now it enters AB in its--
in its dictionary, OK,
in the next location.
So you see, with
a one-step delay,
the AB that was in
the dictionary here
has ended up in the
dictionary of the receiver.
OK, we're done with this.
We now pull in the
next letter here.
That's A. We haven't seen A--
we haven't seen CA
in our dictionary.
So we make an entry for CA,
ship out C. C comes here.
I should say that this was done
with the A. The C comes here,
and the receiver knows
to make an entry for BC.
So with one delay it's got it.
OK, we're done with this.
We pull in the next letter, AB.
That's in our dictionary.
So we keep going, all right?
So this algorithm doesn't look
to ship out the dictionary
address every time it sees a
sequence that it recognizes.
If it's got this already
in its dictionary,
it keeps going to try
and learn a new word.
So it's already got AB
there, so it keeps going
and it pulls in C. And
now that's a new word.
So it's got ABC as a new entry.
It ships out AB--
the address for AB rather.
This gets the address for AB,
which is in its dictionary.
It puts the AB down there.
It takes the first
letter of the string that
came in and appends
it to the last one
that it had there
and gives you the CA.
So you see, it's keeping up
but with a one-step delay.
Let's keep going.
So the AB is done with.
We pull in A. We've got CA.
We pull in the B.
We don't have CAB,
so let's enter that as well.
By the time we've done
this example, by the way,
I'm hoping you'll
know Lempel-Ziv.
So bear with me.
All right, dictionary
entry-- and now
what does it send
out to the receiver?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry.
AUDIENCE: C2
PROFESSOR: CA-- the
address for CA, right?
The address for CA.
So the address for CA comes in.
It decodes the CA.
And so let's see.
We're done with these
pieces, but this one
has to build up its new
direct dictionary entry.
And so what it's got is
the AB setting from before,
and it pulls in
the first letter.
Instead of wrapping
to the next board,
let me start winding up again--
winding upwards.
OK, so that's the new
entry there, the receiver--
one step delayed from here.
OK, I pull in the C. I have BC .
I keep going.
I pull on the A.
I don't see that.
So I need BCA.
I ship out the address for BC.
So I'm done with these.
I get the address for BC here.
I decode and get BC.
I combined the first
letter of the new fragment
with what was sitting here.
So I get CAB as my
dictionary entry.
And I keep going.
All right, it's very systematic.
I'm going to keep
going because there's
a special case that will trip
you up if you don't get to it.
And we need to proceed
a couple more here.
OK, I pull in the
B. I've got a AB.
I pull in the C. I've got ABC.
I pull in the A.
I don't have ABCA.
So I enter that
in my dictionary.
And then I ship out ABC.
OK, so you're always building
a new word, entering it
in your dictionary, and
then the part that's already
known you're
shipping out and then
hanging onto the
end of this to start
building the new fragment.
ABC arrives here.
I had the BC from before.
I pull in the first
letter of that,
and I get a BCA as my new
entry, which is this one.
OK.
Now we pull in the AB.
I mean, we pull in
the B. We have AB.
We pull in the C. We have ABC.
We pull in the A, we have
ABCA, so we pull on the B.
We ship out ABCA--
A-B-C-A. Right?
And now we're done
with all those guys.
And here comes ABCA.
And I go to my dictionary,
and I don't have ABCA--
big hiccup.
So the reason that
happened is that I'm
discovering I need to send
ABCA on the very next step
after entering it in my
dictionary on the receiver--
on the transmitter side.
And so the receiver hasn't
yet had a chance to catch up.
Now if you analyze
this, It turns out
that whenever this happens,
the sequence involved
has its last character equal
to its first character.
So looking at this,
the dictionary
here is waiting to build up.
It's got the ABC
here, and it's waiting
to pull in the first
letter from the sequence--
the sequence associated
with this dictionary entry.
It doesn't have that
dictionary entry.
So it can't pull in the A
like it was doing all along.
But if you analyze the cases
under which this happens,
It turns out that
whenever you don't have it
in your dictionary
entry, the missing letter
that you want to pull
into your dictionary
is the same as the first
one in that string that's
waiting to be built up.
So it completes it with
an A, and it's all set.
Now it says ABCA,
and it continues
So this happens under very
particular conditions.
It's a special case.
If you actually look at the code
that's in the notes you'll see.
While the encoding
is straightforward,
it's really remarkable that
a short fragment like this
can do that encoding.
Let's see here.
I don't want to do this.
I did another example.
Let me just say what's on this
before I dispense with it.
Sorry.
OK.
So look at what's happened.
In terms of the number
of things we've sent,
we've only sent these addresses.
And there are fewer
of them than there
were symbols in the original.
So that's where the
compression comes in.
And as you get the longer
strings, the benefit is higher.
Actually, I'm going to pass
this and just tell you,
when you look through the
code fragment for decoding,
this is the special case
that we talked about.
If the code is not
in your dictionary,
then do such and such.
So that's the explanation.
All right.
And that's described
in the slides.
We'll put that on.
I just wanted to end
with a couple of things.
One is actually-- LZW is a
good example of something
that you see in other
contexts as well, where you're
faced with transmitting
data and you decide instead
that you'll transmit the
model or your best model
for what generates that data.
That can often be a much more
efficient way to do things.
And in fact, when you
speak into your cell phone,
you're not transmitting
a raw speech waveform.
There's actually a very
sophisticated code there
that's modeling your
speech as the output
of an autoregressive filter.
And then it sends the filter
tap weights to the receiver.
So this kind of thing
arises again and again.
Sending the model and
the little information
you need to run the model
at the receiving end
can be much more efficient
than sending the data.
The other thing is
everything we've
talked about has been
lossless compression--
Huffman and LZW.
You can completely recover
what was compressed.
But there's a whole world
of lossy compression,
which is very important.
And we'll find ways to sneak
in discussion of that as well.
All right, thank you.